die stimmung in berlin ist gereizt grund
ist die auflösung einer demonstration
gegen die staatlichen corona maßnahmen
die polizei räumt die bühne des
veranstalters es folgen rufe und pfiffe
und einige demonstranten reagieren mit
sitzblockaden
als die polizei versucht die
veranstaltung aufzulösen stürmen einige
demonstranten zum reichstag
doch wie ist es dazu gekommen bei dem
corona protest wochenende in berlin
wurden 80 veranstaltungen angemeldet die
polizei ist mit 1500 beamten im einsatz
alleine zwischen der siegessäule und dem
brandenburger tor demonstrieren 20.000
menschen gegen die staatlichen krone
auflagen und maßnahmen diese demo will
die polizei dann auflösen
der veranstalter sei nicht in der lage
die vorgeschriebenen hygienemaßnahmen
auf der straße des 17 juni einzuhalten
abstandsregeln sollen nicht eingehalten
worden seien es nur wenige teilnehmer
sollen einen mundschutz getragen haben
[Applaus]